I watched the truth about cancer program where a doctor was treating cancer patients with raw pig for a creus.
Yep, the doctor said it actually takes the protective coating off the cancer cell so that your immune system can kill it.
I don't know if you ever heard of such a thing, but if so, you think there's a benefit to taking pancreatic enzymes and some sort.
I don't remember who's asking this question, but I have written about this in my book.
I also have multiple blog posts about it, multiple video posts about this. This is enzyme therapy.
So enzyme therapy was developed by Dr. William Kelly back in the 1950s.
And the only enzyme really that was available at that time was pork pancreas enzyme.
So that's what he uses pork pancreas enzyme. Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez was a prototype of his.
Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez was a medical doctor that broke off the establishment and practiced in upstate New York for many, many years.
He used Dr. William Kelly's work, but in fact, he wrote a book on Dr. William Kelly.
And this is one another book that he wrote about concrete cancer using pancreatic enzymes and he always used the pancreas pork enzymes.
Now, we have those enzymes on our store. They are through the company allergy research.
That is the exact product that Dr. Gonzalez used.
And we use enzyme therapy for a lot of people. However, I do think that enzymes have improved over the decades, and I wouldn't stick to something just because it was the only thing available at the time.
The negative about using the pancreas pork enzyme alone is that typically that therapy is taking a lot of them.
And we're talking about upwards to 150 capsules a day on an empty stomach.
So enzyme therapy in short is taking enzymes on an empty stomach so that you're not using them to digest food, but you're hopefully absorbing them because you're taking high quantities of them.
And you'll have it excess amount of enzymes circulating in your bloodstream.
And they can break down slash gobble up the waste layer around the cancer so that your immune system can attack it.
So it's very beneficial. We have, we have a number of people doing enzyme therapy.
Now using the newer enzymes, you can typically use far lower dose. We've had people with different cancers use enzyme therapy with great success. So, but I test for that on everybody.
So, if I didn't recommend enzyme therapy for you, it's because it didn't test, but it doesn't mean, you know, things, you may feel that to do that.
So, I have numerous blog posts on enzyme therapy.
I have much rich in about it in my stop by the cancer book as well. And there's some videos on your on this stop by the cancer course and some videos on the website probably but inside therapy.
So, I know it sounds gross, but it's not gross. It's, it's just enzymes. It's pancreatic tissue with enzymes and so there's nothing gross about it so it can be very beneficial.